well unity and
um a strong partnership I think is the
message that they're trying to push out
but for Vladimir Putin it's much more
important than it is for president XI
really
um because he needs president XI a lot
more than president XI needs him given
Russia's isolation on the world stage
given the fact that uh China alongside
India a few other countries are now you
know the most important market for
Russian oil and gas
um you know Russia really needs China
um it's not a particularly even-handed
visit though I think president XI wants
to be considered a a peace broker in
terms of any future resolution and what
happens in Ukraine and in these opening
comments
um at the informal meeting that's going
on now in the Kremlin behind me
President Putin said he'd studied
president xi's 12-point peace proposals
and that they would be discussed now but
if you consider the fact that you have a
three-day State visit to Moscow one most
of the talks will happen tomorrow the
formal talks and then just as far as we
know from the Chinese side a possible
telephone call with Vladimir zielinski
it doesn't really look like a very
evenly balanced attempt to broke a piece
between the two sides and from all the
comments that have been made and both
leaders have written editorials in each
other's daily press this morning
basically bigging each other up talking
about the importance of their strategic
Alliance demonizing America as they so
love to do talking about how America is
is the bully
um you know how they are trying to forge
a peaceful multi-polar world
um I I I think that you know we're not
going to be particularly surprised to
find that peace in our time is not
achieved by the end of the day tomorrow
evening
um I think we'll hear a lot at the end
of the day tomorrow after a press
conference about stronger economic ties
between the two countries we'll hear a
lot about how much they want to push
their multi-polar agenda change what
they consider to be a U.S dominated
world order the question is especially
in Ukraine and America's mind whether
there is a discussion for China to
Supply Military kit to Russia and help
it in its war effort my feeling is that
given the economic blowback of that if
China does that it will be on a minor
level with dual use Technologies and not
in any covert way but certainly the
impression they want to give is that
America is not the only player in the
world here and that Xi Jinping the
Chinese president is a major force in
trying to broker peace and manage
international relations around the world